welcome to this video playing G Rome
from the US so sorry let's see probably
names Oh yep and I'm going to vary my
play a bit with Quincy to not them not
the same ish all the time uh-huh that
that looks very accommodating giving me
this this nice center ok so if he let's
think about it how a moment he wants to
play takes knight c6 attack on d4 I'd
have night before going ok let's let's
make it let's play it really directly
with Queenie for and stuff ensure i was
more expecting g6 but ok
Queenie form will be dangerous
definitely
quite sure what you should play yeah I
was thinking about that I mean it looks
kind of weird because after Bishop
before it's basically a time to retreat
and i have c foyer still see for Queenie
form to which she probably has to play a
five which looks disastrous but now see
for it's not a move that I like to play
very much maybe it's still just good
yeah what can you do Queenie for comes
unless he plays that hahaha I should
have seen that really but okay I have
Bishop before and d5 but also should be
quite good
yeah g5 this is endgame yeah but ok I
mean let's be yeah serious about that I
got two passes in the center no it's
just one pass porn but the kind of are
connected my king my king might be an
issue I guess I want to want to support
the pawns to see develop like night if
aid or something maybe you can play our
Bishop t6 here some single move like
that or Bishop f6 on all move like that
I'm okay
but here I can also go g3 rod maybe we
can still take on a five-play of six on
some stuff like that now he goes back if
I go d6d six he takes a couple of times
King f3 at the end there at how
unnecessary was that from from the phone
that I camp come on should start the
rent right in the middle of the game
king of france even Jackie Bishop g4 but
what can I do
my king is playing playing an active
role and I can maybe take just be seven
okay okay so King f4 now on what is the
best
Jim and came I'm down on 21 something
maybe you can play rookie area just just
move this rook threatened g5 and stuff
like that weird but maybe possible
rookie eight is good yeah okay it is
good I don't really know what to do
against it yeah does this year of course
finds place the opening like whatever
but those kind of moves are found huh f3
yep f3 g5 and rubbish has he known virus
young what okay steady goes into a bad
end game at least i think it's it's not
it's not good maybe f6 just barely holds
maybe
I have success the only move otherwise i
push this out what may be okay but
that's also going to be very tricky fine
yeah maybe I'm still winning this at the
end kingi aidonia that this is the spawn
is just promoting him
rook takes you four was very weird I
mean it's clear that the upcoming
endgame is this very borderline for
black with my active king upon is
totally irrelevant time warning why am I
not winning now look at seven he takes
have I missed something I don't see you
when that's not good with 30 seconds
trying to create weaknesses here okay
that that's helpful you cannot support
it spawns anyway check
check
sure to check every don't know check
check game yeah I'm so slow yeah k
dreadful dreadful dreadful the whole
game of the game I mean and getting
getting a straight wind out of the
opening and white is just winning the
game I just need to be precise and it
starts with this this [ __ ] sorry but
I'm getting angry with myself I mean he
gained this position justjust this for
example play f4 and I mean white is
winning with this just like that it's
nothing not an advantage or better or
whatever white wins and TMP has a great
counter player all of a sudden yeah
Rukia oneness also but I just said this
is just bad came here he could have
played Bishop t6 this was a lots of
better but okay when Timm I'm still a
bit curious about what happened here
gets his check I went here and f3 and
and now looky for is just it's just very
I mean I don't believe in it maybe if he
goes f6 that that that might be that
might be but other than that I thought
them it isn't a good idea yeah let's
check it maybe yeah he can play of six
ok the comp approves and he can go there
ok and this is also ok for black yeah
yeah better for like
like this is to pass Irfan yeah now i'm
playing for wind clearly but yeah yeah I
didn't see the win how do I win here ok
this is what the computer is giving and
then going going with the King King here
I and then looking for I'd the pawn
moves ok ok ok this is the way to do it
ok ok I first didn't spoil it but I
spoiled it afterwards here Ruby 7 I mean
this is all books is seven yeah just
here and then the problem promote ok
yeah he had said it splits full of
arrows I guess captain term it should be
should be a draw of course also in the
yeah in them he and this in the second
game but if we go here he went here he
has to go to e5 yeah so that here he's
counter-attacking against my porn but it
was a crapshoot with no time on the
clock ok thanks for watching